you are a great professor at a very
important high-ranked shanghai-ranking
university
my hero thomas mann when he came to your
country in 1938 giving his lecture to on
the town hall lectures on the common
victory of democracy the coming victory
of democracy he started this lecture you
know who am i you know i'm coming from
hitler germany who am i you american
people the country of whitman and
lincoln to to tell you about democracy
and uh and then he said well he said but
you know
with my experience i know something you
americans probably are not that aware of
because i come from the city where mr
hitler uh and we we you know we lived in
the same city already for for 20 years i
saw i saw the growing fascist movement
he said one of the things i learned is
that the essence of democracy just as
vetlana said is not only you know free
of freedom of votes and that kind of
stuff it's not even institutions it's
the spirit of a democracy if you don't
have if you don't cultivate the spirit
of a democracy then the democracy will
die the institutions etc etc and he said
so how can you take care for the spirit
of democracy it's about
education it's the the base of a
democracy is he said the aim of a
democracy is elevating people and
therefore it aims at education to make
people aware of
science religion art whatever now coming
from the leading of the free world
uh which says everything about europe
that america is still the leader of the
free world um if there's a free world
king i know that um
now then the question is you know if we
see what's happening in america all the
time because in this country we know
more about what's happening in america
than what happens in belgium or germany
um what is going on with your
educational system
i think
for those of us who work in the
education world are sometimes we're
subject to the delusion that somehow
we if we can just order the universities
rightly or if we can order the school
systems rightly we can change the world
that this will be the source of the
revolution of hope right and i think
what we really do have to acknowledge
and you wrote a book called the spirit
of the age
that the spirit of the age the geist
that governs a society at any particular
time is the deepest teacher
it's the deepest teacher it shapes and
guides in a sense every institution
so in the middle ages the spirit of the
age was to know god and the universities
were oriented to knowing god and in uh
you know in the in the the in the in the
ancient world it was philosophy it was
to know the truth and those early
schools were oriented to knowing the
truth today
the spirit of the age is
what is essentially the expansion of the
human of the baconian project of
mastering nature
of mastering human nature of the natural
world of turning everything into an
object of use of something manipulable
alterable subject
to our control and therefore ultimately
oriented to our comfort but which is
ultimately to go back to the idea of the
boomerang is ultimately hollowing out
the very idea of what it is to be a
human because ultimately it's about the
replacement of the human being right so
the idea of the machine so so if we
really want to for education
to be the source of change sadly
we have to change the spirit of the age
and we're in it we're in a bit of uh you
know sort of a uh a chicken and egg
situation here because how does one do
that you do not start yes of course
you need to be a contrarian in your in
the institutions that are otherwise
slavish to the spirit of the age
you can't expect people to interpret the
spirit of the edge if we don't give them
the tools with which to do that we need
to be teaching civics in a way that
makes government relevant to people's
day-to-day lives which we've never done
we need to teach critical thinking and
as we see most importantly i think we
need to teach media literacy we need
media literacy yes and we don't do any
of this
because our teacher as well the problem
is that in the last 30 years
uh people turn away from humanities
they're going to into computer science
so we're discussing morals here and
ethics and stuff like that and history
because we have to know history and you
see that lots of people for example if
you if you take a history student today
you say something that happened six
years ago or one thousand years ago it's
all the same it's the past so they have
they have lost a sense of the past
uh and
you know
i mean greece is very famous for its
poetry let's say how many people
actually read poetry nowadays i mean
poetry has become even more difficult
for for an intellectual uh how many
people actually you said about critical
theory you meet people who actually know
everything that has been written about
moby dick and have read the novel yet
back home i returned from exile some
years ago
to discover five years
seven years after my return that history
had been abolished in the schools
history was not being taught in nigeria
for nearly 10 the military
came
and for some reason or the other decided
we did not need history i said it is not
possible but it was true now an effort
is being made to restore
that but they're looking for teachers
because the teachers went into business
since they were not needed or something
like
i mean that and
increasingly increasingly um this
pressure to make education
functional to business comes from
government i mean it's part of the
rhetoric of all governments it's part of
the accountability system and it's also
um it's also it also reflects a fear on
the part of students
their future is much less secure than it
used to be so what is useful knowledge
what what what what helps you get on
yeah and if and if that's if that's your
uh drive then you know myths and history
and literature are not important
you